y y
love you nein nein hier
nicht zu süß der ist eher frisch muss
man definitiv öfter machen
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute einen
band ok und mit diesem band ok zusammen
wird haben wir mit mir wunderschöne
stunden im grünen verbringen während
picknicken also das ist zumindest der
plan mal gucken ob er überhaupt zeit
herr faber ich hatte die tournatur
zwingend ich starte jetzt direkt mit
unserem tigers wird der band ok das
heißt eigentlich so einen artikel der
bento box wahrscheinlich dass in der
diese boxen wo man sein land mitnehmen
und im band no cache ist einfach so ein
miniatur so eine miniatur torte die
haben wirklich nur so für zwei drei oder
maximal vier personen ist braucht jetzt
auch nur ganz wenig zeit daher bin ich
mir jetzt noch ein richtiges und schlag
das gleich zusammen mit etwas wasser
dann nehmt ihr am besten einfach mit
leitungswasser ich schlage ich das auch
das kommt noch zucker mit dazu und dann
so drei minuten dann mixen dass die
masse auch richtig schön dick wird
[Musik]
ich habe den teig jetzt noch mit vanille
verfeinert und nach den drei minuten
einfach nur noch mehl und backpulver hin
zu 7 und das ganze dann wirklich noch
zehn sekunden unter rühren fertig ist
unser boden den ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und jetzt habe ich hier
meinen torten bringen ich nehme jetzt
echt nur zwölf zentimeter ist der mini
ihn schlage ich hier ein backpapier ein
bisschen so wie es oft werde und dann
den teig einfach einfüllen und dann
verrate ich euch nachher noch die wachs
zeit er muss danach nämlich anschließend
auch vollständig auskühlen
[Musik]
so 20 minuten später also der boden hat
tatsächlich 20 minuten gebraucht und er
sollte jetzt wirklich einmal komplett
auskühlen wie kurz an die seite und
wieder bereit die zwischenzeit unsere
creme vor das ist sowohl die füllung als
auch außen zum verstreichen und
dekorieren von unserer band ok und da
gebe ich jetzt mache ich jetzt am besten
es gibt ja einmal diesen trick dass wir
beides gleichzeitig mixed oder erhebt es
unter in dem fall denke ich können wir
alles zusammen vermischen also hier habe
ich ein bisschen mascarpone es gebe ich
jetzt hier mit rein und die sahne und
wir brauchen auf jeden fall eine weiß
seine hände creme weil wir ja gleich
noch in schönen farben einfärben werden
weil der band ok go ist bekannt dafür
dass er einfach so oft so pastellige
töne hat dürfen auch mal knallige töne
seien aber auf jeden fall sind die immer
bunt
[Musik]
so die sahne masse ist jetzt ein
bisschen dicker geworden aber noch nicht
ganz steif in dem moment fügte er am
besten sahnesteif mit dazu und was ich
heute mache ich so ein bisschen
orangenschalen abriss mit dazu zu geben
da braucht ihr gar nicht viel das ist
nämlich schon so schon sehr intensiv so
das habe ich jetzt mit freigegeben an
saale fest und dann noch mal ein paar
sekunden einen komplett steif schlagen
[Musik]
so fasste dies vergessen zucker kommt
natürlich auch noch mit dazu auch wenn
es nicht so viele ist aber für ein
geschmack ganz wichtig jetzt müssen wir
uns diese creme masse gut aufteilen und
ihr müsst euch am besten schon im
vorfeld gedanken darüber machen was
möchtet ihr für einen design welche
farben sollen es werden ich hab da was
im kopf und daher brauche ich einen ganz
ganz kleinen anteil
gelb auch wirklich nicht viel ich
brauche einen kleinen anteil der weiß
bleiben muss also schätze ich mir das
auch direkt ab dann möchte ich was drauf
schreiben in wahrscheinlich also
richtung rosa da braucht auch nicht so
viel und die die grundfarbe eines bento
keks wird ich weiß es noch gar nichts
kommt immer darauf an wie viel von dem
smart grid ich nehme aber wahrscheinlich
so ein pastellige ist grün und daher
bleibt die größte masse eigentlich in
der schüssel und die wird dann das markt
grün eingefärbt besucher dann irgendwie
pastell grün weil ich bewusst nicht so
viel farbe verwendet so zum dosieren
nehmt euch am besten so ein zahnstocher
verspielt hätte ich fast gesagt und dann
am besten immer sehr wenig nehmen und
dann damit rein wenn ihr dann noch mal
in die farbe rein müsst dann nimmt auf
jeden fall noch mal einen neuen spies
weil mit der sahne da rein ist nicht so
gut denn ist die farbe nicht so lange
haltbar und dann einfach ganz langsam
umrühren und werdet ihr merken das färbt
sich ein und gesagt er braucht noch ein
bisschen was dann gebt einfach mehr dazu
[Musik]
ich habe meine böden aus dem tortenring
geholt am best mit einem back formlose
am äußeren rand entlang fahren und dann
in der mitte einmal durchschneiden und
dann könnt ihr auch schon mal ich habe
jetzt mein eigenes backpapier es ist
nichts was es im onlineshop kaufen könnt
oder so das ist einfach für unser
eigenes café was ja bald eröffnet nicht
mehr lange circa zwei wochen nur noch
und daher habe ich das jetzt einfach mal
benutzt weil ihr braucht auf jeden fall
irgendwie in pergamentpapier oder
backpapier was hier unten drunter gibt
und da kommt es schon mal der erste
boden drauf und dann habe ich mir noch
gedacht ich nehme jetzt hier noch diese
mandarin aus der dose weil könnt ihr
einerseits die flüssigkeit die so ein
bisschen abfangen und damit noch mal die
böden trinken und andererseits natürlich
die mandarin für die zwischenschichten
verwenden so einfach mit einem pinsel
die die flüssigkeit einmal aufsaugen und
hier so ein bisschen drauf tröpfeln
lassen gibt auch noch mal so einen
schönen frischen geschmack so und dann
brauchen wir im prinzip unsere
türkisfarbene creme ich finde die farbe
so geil sieht richtig pastellig aus so
da kommt ein bisschen was ihn
zwischenschichten mandarin noch mal rein
und alles glatt verstreichen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt ein gestrichen und um
ängste würden auch extra ein bisschen
grob also es muss jetzt nicht so akkurat
sein das sind schon so kleine süße
törtchen wo man einfach wirklich einer
fantasie freien lauf lassen darf ihr
könnt alles mögliche machen auch zu
einem möglichen anlässen ich würde jetzt
sagen die staaten jetzt hier erst mal
mit meiner rosa schrift hp sondern
kleine loch tolle vorne dran und das
jetzt wahrscheinlich dem hansa schreibt
weiß ich nicht ich lasse mich einfach
mal inspirierend überraschen was da
sollten herausgesprudelt kommt und dann
dekoriere ich hier nochmal mit weiß und
mit gelb einfach so dass ich spielen
oder sowas darauf mache aber es muss ich
mir überlegen außerdem haben sie für
eine botschaft sage so dieses ganze
klassische
anlaufpunkt
im visier dass nebenbei reformer und
jetzt wird gleich noch mal hoch hier
könnte ich diese festhalten hast du so
eine ruhigere hand und bei einer torte
gibt es immer eine schöne und eine
hässliche seite die schöne seite endlich
nach vorne
genau das hat entsprechend seht ihr
glatt die hässliche aber jede torte
schön und hässlich oder ganz normal so
und jetzt schreibe ich nie drauf und
dann kommen noch dazu
[Musik]
so wir haben uns jetzt hier ein
gemütliches plätzchen gesucht haben soll
das müssen wir nicht auf der wiese oder
meditiert
auf jeden fall ist das ein band ok
psion die ly
so dass schon
mal
dass ein band und japanische genau aber
in bento box ist eigentlich eher so eine
box mit ja so eingeteilte kunststoffe
oder gas
und zuckerrohr box nimmt und dann ist
das der turbo quasi dann weiß man jetzt
ist der hand nicht mit der hand oder
nach
deren angaben können wir machen wir aber
nicht wir nehmen's ein glas tja dann
gehen wir da gleich so rein ja dann
haben wir den kuchen im klar
ich bin hier am besten mal hin
das
ist ihm egal ich finds also oder obwohl
doch es geht so und jetzt bekommst du
mich aber nein nein das
stück
kommt mir schon diese ganzen
tierschützer sagen darf kein kuchen da
ist zu reden also ich find auch wer
nichts süßes ist er frisch die mandarin
finde ich perfekt was man richtig gut
also nimmt auf jeden fall noch eine
frucht mit rani mandarin sind verfügbar
ist aber nicht gewidmet und dabei
muss man definitiv öfter machen so ein
süßes pick denke mir auch kekse die
stücke noch bei käufern einkaufen das
ging ja fritz koch schnell also thunerin
orangenschalen abnehmen also echt der
lecker leute macht gerne nach geht raus
genießt die sonne mit eure freunde müsst
also ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
wahrsagen bis zum nächsten mal so
[Musik]